Hallo Deutschschule
Aussprachetraining “ch” und “sch”.
Der Frosch, die Frösche.
Der Frosch hüpft über die Wiese.
Der Frosch fängt eine Fliege.
das Eichhörnchen
Das Eichhörnchen isst gerne Nüsse.
Das Eichhörnchen rennt schnell.
der Schokoladenkuchen
Heute backe ich einen leckeren Schokoladenkuchen.
Hmm, dieser Schokoladenkuchen schmeckt so gut…
die Chilischote
Die Chilischote ist scharf.
Heute koche ich eine Suppemit scharfen Chilischoten.
Scharfe Chilischoten sind gesund.
Isst du gerne scharfe Chilischoten?
der Schatz
die Schatzkarte
Der Schatz ist auf der Schatzkarte eingezeichnet.
Die Piraten sind auf der Suche nach dem Schatz.
Aber wir Deutschlerner haben den Schatz!
Wir haben den Wortschatz!
China
In China gibt es sehr köstliches Essen.
Das chinesische Essen isst man mit Stäbchen.
die Stäbchen
die Schuhe
die hochhackigen Schuhe
Die hochhackigen Schuhe nennt man High Heels.
die Turnschuhe
Die Turnschuhe trägt man beim Sport.
die Anzugschuhe
Die Anzugschuhe trägt man im Büro.
die Fußballschuhe
Die Fußballschuhe trägt man beim Fußballspielen.
die Skischuhe
Die Skischuhe trägt man beim Skifahren.
die Bücher
In der Bibliothek gibt es viele Bücher.
Ich lese am liebsten Kochbücher.
Liest du auch gerne Bücher?
das Schloss, die Schlösser
In Deutschland gibt es viele schöne Schlösser.
Das berühmteste Schloss in Deutschland
ist “Schloss Neuschwanstein”.
das Licht
In der Disco gibt es viele grelle Lichter.
Das Licht meiner Taschenlampe leuchtet hell.
Jetzt geht mir ein Licht auf!
der Chef
Der Chef leitet das Unternehmen.
Heute habe ich ein Gespräch mit meinem Chef.
Der Chef in einem Krankenhaus ist der Chefarzt.
Der Chef in der Küche ist der Küchenchef.
der Fisch
Der Fisch schwimmt im Ozean.
Der Goldfisch schwimmt im Aquarium.
Juhu, ich habe einen Fisch gefangen!
Fischers Fritze fischt frische Fische :)
die Milch
Die Milch ist in einem Tetrapack.
Ich trinke meinen Kaffee immer mit Milch.
Wie trinkst du deinen Kaffee?
der Schrank
Der Schrank für die Kleider
ist der Kleiderschrank.
Heute nehme ich mir ein schönes
Sakko aus dem Kleiderschrank.
schreiben
Ich schreibe mit einem schönen Stift.
Am liebsten schreibe ich mit einem Kugelschreiber.
Manchmal benutze ich aber auch
einen Bleistift zum Schreiben.
Schreibst du eigentlich mit rechts oder mit links?
der Elch
das Elchgeweih
Der Elch besitzt ein großes Elchgeweih.
der Kelch
Der König trinkt aus einem goldenen Kelch.
Oh, oh! Der König hat zu viel
Wein aus seinem Kelch getrunken.
schwarz
Alexandra trägt ein schwarzes Kleid.
Die schwarze Handtasche passt
perfekt zum schwarzen Kleid.
der Schal
Im Winter trage ich einen warmen Schal.
Sophia trägt beim Skifahren einen schicken Schal.
die Chemie
das Chemielabor
der Chemiker, die Chemikerin
Die Chemiker arbeiten in einem Chemielabor.
der Chemielehrer, die Chemielehrerin
Die Chemielehrerin unterrichtet Chemie inder Schule.
schwimmen
das Schwimmbad
Der Schwimmer schwimmt in einem Schwimmbad.
Schwimmst du auch gerne in einem Schwimmbad?
Werde Mitglied unseres Youtube-Kanals
und unterstütze uns mit einem kleinen Betrag!